la unión europea aumentó de 300 a 600
millones las dosis compradas a facer y
vayan tec esto implica que el bloque
comunitario se ha asegurado casi la
mitad de la producción total de esta
alianza para el año 2021
la vacuna de fisher y bryant es la única
en circulación hasta el momento a la
espera de que los 180 millones de dosis
adquiridos a modernas comiencen a
distribuirse tras su aprobación which is
you is right track since con estas dos
vacunas autorizadas ya hemos asegurado
una cantidad de dosis necesaria para
vacunar a 380 millones de europeos esto
es más del 80% de la población europea y
otras vacunas seguirán en las próximas
semanas y meses en adwords sólo en
déjame luís symonds
la noticia se ha dado el mismo día en
que un estudio científico preliminar
señaló que la vacuna de facer y buy and
text sería efectiva con las variantes
británica y sudafricana algo muy
importante ya que europa está sufriendo
un rebrote severo del virus en pleno
plan de vacunación un proceso que ha
sufrido duras críticas por la falta de
medios y la lentitud pero que los más
afectados siguen considerando
fundamental que la vacunación es muy
importante primero es una cuestión de
respeto que protege a ti pero también
protege a los demás y eso es muy
importante si pensamos en los médicos y
trabajadores de la salud que pagaron un
alto precio para combatir esta pandemia
es completamente ilógico negarse a
recibir la vacuna
con este acuerdo la unión europea tiene
asegurados 2300 millones de dosis una
cifra que sirve para vacunar a más del
doble de su población algo que contrasta
con los países más pobres del planeta
que apenas tienen acuerdos cerrados con
las compañías farmacéuticas